色界業による肉声 ウパー・ウチェレ・カンナ・カア・カッターナ
まああの あまり難しいところではなくて
あの 色界の洗浄か 色界の心を作ったらどこに生まれるかっていう
どこでその結果を得られるかっていうことなんです
まあ大体このアビダンマではこの来世のことばっかし書いてるような感じがしますけどね
アビダンマでは お釈迦様はまあそんなにこの来世
将来を目指して頑張るということはあまり気にしてないんです
お釈迦様でもすごいこの自由な思想を持ってましたし
どんな伝統的な思想であろうとも
まあ意味がない場合は全部まあ壊してしまっちゃったんだから
であの あまりあの初期仏教から見れば
この来世来世とそればっかし目指して頑張っちゃうと
まあいろいろ社会的な
まあ危険性もあるんですね
結果は将来ですよと言ってね
どんな どんなものにも人々を
もうどんなものをさせることはできるんです
ですから それはすごい危険な
まあ特に宗教の世界ではね
神様のために戦争しなさいと言ったらね
もうそれでできるだけ人を殺してしまっちゃって
それで自分たちがもう神様に言われた通りにやったと
だから天国に行くんだと
もうすごい勘違いするんですね
でも もし殺生っていうのは悪いことであるならばね
その人々は完全に騙されるし
またかえって社会に大変な迷惑かけるというね
まあ損害を与えるということになっちゃうんですね
ですから このあまりこの将来の天国の約束というかね
そういうものを宗教としてはあまりふさわしくないという立場をお釈迦様は持ってるんですね
でも一般の世界では もう死んでから天国に生きるために
もうみんな宗教というもの
宗教というどんなくだらないものでもやってるんですね
だからこの伝統的な この文化的な
この固定概念と お釈迦様がおっしゃっている宗教というのは
もうなかなか合わないんですね
で 将来のことを見て頑張るということは
結局いろいろ危険があるんだから
お釈迦様はそれをまあ抑えておくんですね
おっしゃってないわけじゃないんです
いいことをすれば まあ将来もいいところに行きますよと
でもそれだけ自分が道徳を守る衝動にするならば
それは良くないと で まあ純粋たる道徳
道徳であるならば構いませんだけど
この道徳自体っていうのはなかなかもう分かりにくいもんなんですね
何が正しいものか 何が悪いものかっていうことは
この世の中の哲学からはなかなか判断しにくいんですね
で なぜならば 道徳の世界で平気で人殺しも道徳って正当化しているんだからね
ある人を殺してもいいし
ある人は殺してはいけないんだと
だから それはどんな立場ですかと聞くと
まったくくだらない立場を言うんですね
例えば ある宗教を信仰している人々は
その宗教を信仰しているんだからありがたいと
信仰してない人々はまあ殺してもいいと
これ邪教とかね まあパガンですかね
英語の言葉でね パガンという人々はこの
まあ別にという風になってるんですね
だからまあなかなか道徳っていうのはもういい加減なんですね
世の中にある道徳っていうのは
で そのその人々は自分に自分の都合により道徳価値観を変えちゃうんですね
政治家が自分の都合による社会道徳を決めると
また政治システム変えちゃったら
また違う道徳を作ってしまっちゃうんですね
だからそれを真面目にもう守る人間はどうなるかというと
もう誰も約束してくれないんですね
もうどうなるかっていうことに
だからこの世の中の道徳っていうのは
もうろくなものではないということは
まあ仏教から言えるんですね
ですから 仏教ではものすごい基本的な
この普遍的な道徳を作ってるんですね
いわゆる貪瞋痴に基づく行為は悪い行為であって
不貪不瞋不痴に基づく行為は
その不貪不瞋不痴が衝動になっている行為は
すべてが善であると そうするとそこには時空関係はないんですね
どんな時代であろうとも
貪瞋痴は人にあるし 不貪不瞋痴は人に
生命にあるし 人だけではなくて
神々 人間 動物 地獄 餓鬼
すべての生命にその貪瞋痴の働きがあるんですね
だから小さな虫を見たっても
我々にはもう確実に貪瞋痴によって行動していることは見えるんですね
ですから 貪瞋痴に基づく行動はすべてが不善であって
不貪不瞋不痴に基づいた行動はすべてが善であると
そこでもう絶対的な道徳というものはもう仏教でもう作ってるんですね
それは神様とかね そういう概念はまるっきり捨ててしまってるんですね
単なる心理学的な まあ立場で道徳っていうものはまあきちんと成立しているんですね
それは誰にも否定できないんだと
どんな宗教の人にもそれだけは否定できないんだと
否定するならば その人は必ず自己矛盾しているんだと
ですから 例えば人殺しを正当化している宗教の聖書なんか読んでみたっても
聖書の中ではいろいろ聖書世の中でありますからね
ちゃんと人を愛すること
人を助けること 仲良くすること
平和を守ることは道徳であると書いてあるんです
怒りこそ道徳ですよと
怒りで行動するべきですよとは書いてるところはないんです
世の中に それなのに 人々は自分の都合により
まあ怒りと欲を正当化しているんですね
それはその人々は自分の宗教にも逆らっていることなんですね
だから無知ですから そこはわかってないんですね
最近気がついたんだけど
ローマ法王ほど頭の悪いバカもんのおじいちゃんがいないんだ
もうなんか喋ったらむちゃくちゃでね
もう自分の宗教にも もう本当はもう
聖書を信じていないかもしれませんね
まあカトリック教だから
いろんなくだらないことばっかり信仰しているんだからね
一応まあイエスは信じていないんですね
いろんな仙人とかね まあもうマリア様とかね
それからあるとある聖人というんですか
この聖人というね まあいろいろそういう連中を信じているんですね
ですから まあ純粋カトリック宗教ではないんだけど
とにかく頭が悪いということはまあ正真正銘なんですね
いい加減なことをずっと言いっぱなしで
日本ではあまり問題にしませんだけど
外国では結構 カトリックの人々もね
たまに言うんですね ちょっとしっかり物事を考えたらどうですかとか
まあとにかくまあ道徳に逆らうことを言うと
自分たちの宗教にも違反するんです
そういうわけで お釈迦様は徹底して道徳を作った
そのだからといって貪瞋痴をやめて不貪不瞋痴の行為をしたならば
来世は良くなりますよと
というと またそこに矛盾になっちゃうんですね
そこで今世ではまあ苦労しなさいと
まあしょうがないと 来世は良くなるんだと
それは心理を正当化することにならないんですね
ですから 正しい法則であるならば
結果はすぐ即座に出てこなきゃいけないというのが仏教の考え方なんですね
言っていることは正しいであるならば
それを実行したら 結果はすぐその場で出てこなくちゃいけないんだと
百年経ったところで結果出るとかね
あるいは一億年経ったところで結果が出るというと
まあちょっと あまりよくない
ですから 仏教の因果法則というものはすぐ
原因揃ったらすぐそこに結果があるんだと
そこに時間がかかるならば
それはその原因ではないと
で そういう風にはなってるんですね
ですから このなんとか禅定を作ったんだから
死んでから梵天に生まれるということでアビダンマで書いてますけど
本当は禅定とか何か作ったならば
その人にはその瞬間からもそのいい結果が得られるんです
その第一禅定であろうが
第四禅定であろうが  5番目の禅定であろうが
作った人にとってはその現世的な現世利益というか
このその幸福を その平和な心
あの慈しみ まあ喜悦感味わえる
充実感味わえる心が作られるんですね
ですから 禅定を作った人はその瞬間からあの本当に落ち着いて生活できるはずなんですね
今まですごい混乱しながら
悩みながら いろんな苦しみを味わいながら
心の激しい波で ありとあらゆる精神的なストレスで悩んでいた人が
もし禅定を作ったならば
それは一切それっきりでもうなくなっちゃうんですね
心は平安で落ち着いて
また充実感を味わいながら生きるということができるんですね
だからかなり高度な心の波が生まれるんですね
このすごい高次元的な心が生まれるんですね
世の中を見ると 人間というのは
このなかなかこの高次元的な思考と高次元的なところに心を持っていることは好きじゃないんですね
低次元でいたいんですね
で それを仏教の例えで言うならば
皮膚病の人はあの体を掻くことを楽しむんだと
皮膚病でも痒くてたまらないんですね
それで掻くんですね 掻くと気持ちいいんです
そこで掻くことにはいろいろ工夫するんですね
どう掻けば気持ちいいんですかと
そればっかりやってて
じゃあそれ薬を使ってあの掻くことをやめてくださいと言ったら
あまり好きじゃないんですね
やっぱり掻いてしまっちゃうんですね
掻いたらまたあの病気がまた広げちゃうんですね
あの細菌がずっと広げちゃいますからね
皮膚体中 広げて広げて
まああっちこっち掻いたりすると
あの健康的な皮膚あるところにまた病気が移ってしまったりして
いて で そういう喜びを感じているんですね
ですから この病気を治してもらって
全然掻けない状態になるのは嫌なんですね
それわからないので 何が面白いかと
今せっかく面白いなのにというふうに考えているんです
ですから この心はこの高次元的にいくということは
なかなか 好きではないみたいの条件も世の中にあるんですね
で 自分たちにはなんか超能力あるんだとかね
いろんな高次元的な能力があるんだという人々は
みんな一般の人間よりは低次元的な世界に入っているということはよく見えるんです
まあとにかく禅定っていうのは大変高次元的な心で
まあ人間のレベルも乗り越えていて
ですから まあそういう人々
かなり落ち着いて まあ無執着の心で生きることはできるんです
で そういう人々は亡くなったらどうなるかっていうことはここで書いてあるんであって
禅定の結果は死ぬまで得られないという意味ではないんです
で パタマッジャーナンパリッタんばーウェッタブラフマパーリサッジェスウッパッジャティ
第1禅定を弱く修行すると
あの第1番目の梵天ですね
それはブラフマパーリサッジェと書いているんですね
日本訳では何でしたっけ
梵衆天 いわゆるあの梵天
梵天として生まれますが
まあ一般梵天なんですね
その梵天の次元で まあ一般民として生まれるということで
で マッジマンバーウェッタは中ぐらいの
もっと力強く禅定を作るとブラフマプローヒテ
梵布天 もうもっと梵天でももっとレベルちょっと高い
いわゆる権力ある梵天として生まれるということなんですね
で 強く修行すれば大梵天に奏じると
マハァ・ブラフマ で もっとレベル高いところに生まれ変わるんですね
そこでこの梵天に生まれても
そこにもやっぱり衆生の差があるんですね
平等というわけじゃないんです
で あの それも考えてほしいもので
まあ基本的には生命は平等なんですね
虫も人間も神々もみんな生命だから
生命としてはみんな同じなんですね
法則はみんなに同じなんです
生命には差がないんです
だからといって平等な生命二人も見つからないんです
この存在の中で みんな互いに違うんです
全く同じ人間二人がいたんだとかね
他の虫でもいいんだけど
全く同じ虫一匹二匹いるんだということはありえないんです
それぞれみんな違うんです
ですから この輪廻の中に生きている生命は
基本的にはこの 何て言います
基本的には平等なんですけど
実際には平等な生命は一人もいないんです
だからその考え方も あの
仏教でしか見当たらない考え方なんですね
ですから 平等であって
また実際には平等ではないんだと
その 生命っていうのは
そのなりのね いろいろ組み立ててできるものだから
その時その時の原因によって組み立てる現象ですからね
生命っていうのは 別に実体があるわけじゃないし
ですから その場でその場でその差が出てくるんですね
特に生命っていうのは
決まるのは心ですから
物体ではないんだからね
物体の中に心が活動すると生命というんです
生きているものというんですね
で 心が活動しないと その物体にただの物体というんですね
ルーパだけですね ですから
ナーマとルーパが一緒に行動すると
そこは生命ということになっちゃうんですね
そこで心の働きによって生命の差が
差っていうのはもう決めてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 同じ人間でもいつでも同じというわけじゃないんですね
ずっと変化していくんですね
生まれた赤ちゃんが まあその占ってでももらって
この赤ちゃんがどんな性格ですかとか何とかと占ってもらっても
ずっとその通りになるということはないんです
その場でその場で その環境によって
因果関係によって 性格も何だかんでも変わって変わっていくんですね
限りなく変わっていくんです
[咳]固定していないんですね
今 優しい人がずっと死ぬまで優しいというわけにはいかないんです
今 優しい人はすぐ優しくない人間になる可能性もまたあるんですね
それはもう環境によって変わってしまうんですし
心の働き方によっても変わってしまうし
だから環境に心がどう対応するかっていうことによって変わってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから だから心が育てる必要があるんだと
心が育てるというのは
環境が変わっても心はいい状態で守るという
保すということは 心の育ち方
修行になっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 仏教では修行というものは必ずしも必要なものであって
無料で何かもらうということはないんですね
で 心はすぐ環境の影響を受けて変化しちゃう
環境の操る人間になっている
そうするともう変化するだけであって
どうなるかとわからないんですね
わかる 理解することはできない
今 優しい人はちょっと良くない環境に入った途端
優しくない人間になってしまっちゃうんですね
我々に予測できませんから
人はどんな環境で一生生きているかっていうことはね
ですから 心の状態も予測できない
それで心を育てるということをするんですね
心を育てるということは
環境によって左右されない
心の清らかな状態を頑固と守られるような強い心を作るんですね
普通の心だったら得すると喜ぶんですね
損すると落ち込むんですね
褒めるとものすごく舞い上がっちゃうんですね
貶されるとものすごく落ち込んで
また怒りを発生して ものすごく恐ろしくなってしまっちゃうんですね
だから環境というのはラーバ
アラーバ ニンダー パサンサー
ラーバというのは得 アラーバというのは損
ニンダーっていうのは貶せる
貶すこと パサンサーっていうのは褒めること
それがラーバ アヤソー
ヤソー アヤソーっていうのは名誉
名誉じゃなくて不名誉
自分の名誉がなくなっちゃう
ヤサっていうのはすごく名誉
有名になってしまうという
それからスカル ドゥッカ
楽になる あるいは苦しくなるという
8種類のものは世の中でずっと回転しているんだと
それは世の中のことだから
我々にコントロールできない
損する 損するか得するかということは自分で決めるものじゃなくて
世の中の物事 物事の流れによって起こるものであって
で 貶されるか褒める 褒めるというのもまた世の中の勝手であって
私の希望によって褒めてもらうとかね
批判してもらうということはあり得ないんですね
ですから この8種類のローカダンマ
世の中の法則というものがありますね
アッタローカダンマというんですね
それによって心が変化するんですね
決まってる 変化するんですね
得をするとすごく喜ぶ
舞い上がっちゃう 損すると落ち込んでしまうと苦しみを味わうと
で 褒めてもらうとまた舞い上がっちゃう
貶されるとまた落ち込んでしまっちゃうと
気持ち悪くなっちゃうとかね
ですから 世の中の意のままなんですね
心っていうのは それで良いんですかと
それは決していいわけじゃないんですね
あまりにも弱くて 決していいわけじゃないんですね
ですから 体はコントロールできないんですね
体は物質だから 物質の法則によって変化していく
心は物質を支配しているものですから
我々はそれで修行というもの
心を育てるということをお釈迦様はそれでおっしゃっているんですね
で 仏教の心を育てる基本がそういう基本で
それを他の宗教と比べてみるとわかると思いますけど
で 神様に逆らったんだから人は修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
キリスト教によると あるいはユダヤ教によると
神様がそういうそういう決まり
戒律を決めたんだから
人間がそれをやらなくちゃいけない
それは神との約束なんですね
そういうふうなこの立場が仏教にはないんですね
それは神との約束ではなくて
現実に自分の心を見ると心が弱いということは見えるんですね
どんな人間でも どんな犬猫でも褒めると舞い上がっちゃう
貶しちゃうと落ち込んじゃう
犬でも牙見せちゃうんですね
あまり貶したりいじめたりすると凶暴になってしまうと
だからそれは具体的な事実なんですね
それで生きるということは心でやっているものだから
心はそういうふうなこの
どんなものにも影響を受けて変化する心はいくらか強い状態に
何があろうとも平安な心を保つと
いわゆる得を得する時でも平安な心でいる
舞い上がらないと 損する時でも全く平気で平安な心でいると
そうすると外の影響は受けないような強い心ができちゃうんです
そこもまあ 道徳の基本的なところで理解してほしいところなんですね
それで 生命は平等でないということをことを話してきましたからね
それそういうわけで 心が同じじゃないんだから
そもそも生命が生きている環境は同じじゃないんだから
同一の生命は二人を見つからないんです
同じ家族の兄弟であろうとも
その人の人が育てる環境は変わるんですね
時間的に見ても変わってるんですね
前に生まれた人と後で生まれた人と
そうするとそこで環境違っちゃうんですね
三年前に生まれた子と三年後で生まれた子っていうのは
前の子は三年間のそのうちの経験を受けているし
新しく生まれた子はまだ経験を持ってないんです
それはずっと同じな その立場が
その経験の差っていうのは変わらないんです
ですから たとえ兄弟であろうとも
育てる環境は違いますから
それなりに心も変わってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 生命はまあ基本的には平等なんですが
実際は平等ではないと
その生命は平等でないということは差別感につながりますかというと
それはつながりません
差別は不可能なんです
なぜならばみんな違いますから
差別をすると切りがないんです
自分一人に比べて 世界はあなた違いますよ
あなたも違いますよとかね
差別をしたらその人は生きていられないんです
だから世の中で差別感があるのは
無知な人々の間で差別という概念があるんですね
白人は同じだと思っているバカどもが黒人を差別する
そういうふうに 民衆の間で我々何々民衆だと
だから同じだと それは全く無知な概念なんですね
例えば我々日本人だと言ったっても
日本人みんな同じですかね
ただ日本語喋るだけで似ているだけのこと
それ日本語も同じ日本語喋ってる
喋ってないでしょうに
それぞれみんな違う日本語喋ってるし
年取った人の日本語と若者の日本語
東京の人の日本語と 青森の方の日本語とかね
東北の日本語とか それぞれまた違うし
東北弁にしたっても また年によって使っている言葉はまた違ってるしね
だから全くそういうのは無知な概念なんですね
日本人だという ただまあ日本語
日本で生まれたことと日本語喋ることぐらいしか共通点はないんですね
それをもって我々日本人だ
他の人々はそうでないと差別するというのはあまりにも無知な行動なんですね
ですから 人間というのはすぐ差別したがっちゃうんです
昨日ちょっとテレビで見たんだけど
ただあの ちょっと違うだけで
恐ろしく学校でなんかはね
いじめられる いじめたりするんだと
そういうのは この 人間としてできてないというね
文化的な人間になってないということなの
国際結婚している人々
なんかこの必ずテレビに出る有名な人なんですか
自分は大変苦労しましたとね
子供たち育てる場合は
ただ単に父親が母親がアメリカ人ですからね
あの場合は ただそれだけで自分の好きにね
お前もう死ねとかね 学校に来るなとかね
そういうふうなものを書いたりまで書いておいたりとかね
ノートやらあっちこっちとかね
だから子供にそんなこと言われるとね
まあどれぐらい精神的にショック受けるかと
だからまあ恐ろしい社会なんですね
だから そういうふうに差別する子供たちも
もう子供たちだからといって許すわけにいきませんし
それは親の教育なんですね
親は完全たるもう文化人じゃないんだから
そういうふうに子供を育てるんですね
今日もこっち来ると この幼稚園の子
幼稚園から小学生もたくさんの子連れで出ていたんだけどね
みんなすごい可愛いんですね
一人の子だけは見て気持ち悪くなっちゃったんです
その子のお母さんがそばにいたんです
ここら辺だからすごいかっこつけて
もう見栄ばっかしで もうだからまあ本人が威張ってるんだけど
私に映る映像はなんかこのどっかの便所に潜り込んで立ち上がったような感じなんですね
気持ち悪いんですね 出す出す体から出す心の波動っていうのはものすごい臭い
醜いんですね こんな綺麗な服を着てね
高価なアクセサリーつけてあったっても
心読める人にとってはそれは見えないんです
だからすっごい気持ち悪い波動が出てくるんですね
他の子供たちの母親がついていなかったんだからね
もうただそれなりに もううるさくて
遊びながらね みんなもう並んでずっと駅に入っていたんだけど
それは可愛いんですね
見るのは ですから でもその子供たちにはちゃんとした
このそういうできてない母親がついているんだからね
で 結局いじめとかそういうもの出てこないです
出てくるんですね ですから
そういうのはそういうふうに理解する
僕 僕の言葉通りに激しく理解しなくちゃいけないんです
そういう人を差別する
動物でも差別する人々はもうできてないんです
人間になってないんです
動物そのまんまなんです
形だけ人間で 私は何々人だとあなた方はそうではないと思う気持ち
その考え方自体も 仏教の道徳ではものすごい恐ろしい非道徳だと書いているんです
だから道徳っていうのは慈しみの気持ち
みんな同じだとと思う気持ちは道徳であって
違うんだと差別的に思うのは道徳じゃないんですね
そこでみんな似てないと思うことを
またこの平等感に必要なんですね
私とすべての生命は違うんだと
それはしょうがないんだというところで
相手の差を認める気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
ある人はものすごい大きい声で喋ると
それでその人を差別されて
その人をいじめるということはありえないんですね
なんであんただけでっかい声で喋ってるんですかと
しょうがないでしょう
その人はそういう風にできてるんだから
みんな互い違いますよということを理解することは
決して差別感にはつながらないんですね
ある人の声はすごく小さいと聞こえないほど小さいと
それに腹が立って こいつは言葉喋れないんだとかね
言葉喋れないんだったら学校に来るなとかね
毒を飲んで死んでしまえとかね
そういうふうに言うのは
どんな気持ちで言うか
僕らには想像もできないんですね
その子がどうすればいいんですかね
そういう風に生まれたならば
低い声で小さな声で生まれたならば
それでこのどんな生命も互いに違いますよと理解することも
この差別感のためではなくて
慈悲の気持ちを 慈しみの気持ちを作るために必要なものなんです
それまた事実なんですね
単なる信仰ではないんです
生命は互いに違いますよということも
似ている生命二人はいませんと
この輪廻の中で それをわかった人にとってはすごく豊かで平和で
社会の中で生きている生きることができるんです
相手を抑えようとかね
いじめようとかね 自分の希望通りに相手をなんとかなんとかして変化させようとかね
そうはならないんですね
そうするんだから 社会の中で
この人間関係の中で ありとあらゆる問題
トラブルが生まれてくるんです
ですから その仏教のこの道徳価値観というのは
あのずっと普遍的なものであって
過去にも作用しましたし
現在にも作用するし これからの人類にも作用するし
人類は破滅することをしますけど
それはもし延期して欲しければ
仏教の道徳観を守るしか道がないんですね
もし人間はこの仏教で言っている正しい道徳観
事実に基づいた道徳観を守るならば
人類破滅というのはありえないんです
この自然破壊とかね 互いに戦争をすることとかね
一つもありえなくなっちゃうんです
でも 物質的な法則によって
やがて地球は滅びる見ます
もう太陽に支えられているんだから
太陽は燃えっぱなしだからね
それは誰にも避けることはできないんです
いくら瞑想したっても
太陽はもう爆破しないということはありえないことですからね
そういう滅びることはあり得ますけど
ほとんど人類は滅びるのはこの物質
宇宙の法則に基づいてではなくて
人間の心の乱れ 心が恐ろしくなりまして
お互いに殺し合いをしているんですね
それをずっと我々はやっているんですね
心が恐ろしい ですから
互いに人々を殺しやっているんです
そういうことで この生命はどこにも平等じゃない
そこで たとえ禅定を作って
大慈禅定を作っても そこにも差があるということなんですね
自分の禅定の力によって
この力が小中大に分けているんですね
心はどれぐらい強力に集中しましたかと
例えば中途半端にあのなんとか頑張ってちょっと集中力生まれたという場合は
大慈禅定のようなものが生まれるかもしれませんだけど
何の力もない という場合もあります
例えば大慈禅定を作った人は
今世において大変幸福を味わう
ものすごい喜悦感 味わう
充実感味わうんです でも
たわわすかな力だったら
その禅定が 強力になるまで育ててないならば
大したことはないんですね
ですからまあこんなわずかにその人の心落ち着いたかもしれませんだまた社会に入って大胆な打撃を受けると
あの禅定状態は壊れてしまって
また混乱な心生まれる可能性はありますね
ですから その心のもう強さの差なんですね
そういうことで この で
禅定を作っても それは修行に修行の力によって小と中と大に分けてあって
梵天にもそういう風に三次元は考えられてるんですね
生まれ変わった時も 一般の梵天で生まれるか
いくらかの格の高い梵天で生まれるか
大梵天で生まれるかっていう風な差が出てくるんです
それで梵天の中でもリーダーシップ取って他の梵天を指導している人々もいるんです
その世界でも 我々人間の世界でも
ただ生きている人間もいるし
いくらか立場があって生きている人間もいるし
人々のリーダーになってリーダーシップを取って生きている人々もいるし
その差を梵天に至っても同じことで
そこら辺に何とか梵天という名前で無名でいる梵天もいるし
かなり名前売れているリーダーシップ持ってる
梵天もいるし 例えば経典でよく出てくるサハンパティという梵天
結構頭がいい人々のことをよく心配する梵天なんですね
このお釈迦様に説法してくださいと
生ゲロンじゃないんだと
言ったのはこのサハンパティという梵天なんですね
ですから 彼が彼が梵天にいるんだけど
かなり大きな人なんですね
他の生命のことやら物事やらもう心配するんですね
どうすればよろしいかとかね
いわゆる立派な政治家みたいなもんなんですね
だからお釈迦様はブッダになったところで
ブッダになったら梵天の次元は全部乗り越えて
ものすごい偉い状態になったんだけど
やっぱりリーダーには一言言える力があるんです
リーダーだから お釈迦様はもうみんな仏教は理解しないと思ってますけど
もし説法しなかったならば
もう人類はどうなるんですかと
誰にもこの真理を知る道がなくなるでしょうと
それで何人かでも理解できる人々がいるでしょうし
みんな平等じゃないんだから
ただ見る限りみんな頭が悪いと分かっていても
だからといって一切生命の頭が悪いというわけじゃないんだからね
もうちょっと気をつけて世の中を見てください
見たところで見て説法してくださいと
で 言われたら お釈迦様もやっぱりそういう人類のことを
生命のことを心配する人々の言葉っていうのは無視するわけにはいきませんしね
自分のために言ってるわけじゃないんだからね
ですから 考えたところで
そういえば私に仏教 私に真理をね
教えてくれた先生二人が結構頭が良かったんではないかと
そこからこの結構貪瞋痴はなかったんではないかと
心は優れて清らかな心を持っていたでしょうと
そういう方々にはわかるんだと
ということで 説法しようと始めたんですね
ですから このサハンパティとかね
そういう梵天の名前なんかは経典に残ってるんですね
でも一人二人じゃなくて
もうものすごいたくさん梵天がいるんだけど
あまり名前も誰も知らない
で 何人かの名前は一応経典では残っている
頭の悪い梵天としてバカという名前のバカブラフマという梵天の名前が出ているんだけど
それ名前なんかはあだ名ですけどね
ですから サハンパティっていうのはすごいかっこいい名前なんですね
それ名前自体はものすごいリーダーという名前なんですね
ちょっと意味はちょっとわかりにくいんですけど
パティっていうのはリーダーっていう意味でサハンっていうのはサハン
これソヤンパティからソヤンパティはサヤンパティになっちゃうし
サハンですからね ちょっと意味がわからないんですけどね
まあ一応リーダーっていうことで
バカっていうのはこの
やっぱりパーリ語でもバカって意味なんですね
大体頭が悪い場合は もう悪い人を示す場合は大体そういう名前が出てくるんですね
名前として ほとんどパーリ経典やらパーリ仏典で出てくるのはあだ名ばっかし
その梵天が頭が悪くてお釈迦様にチャレンジして
お釈迦様もそのチャレンジを受けて競争して負けてしまったと
梵天が あのバカっていうのは
このパーリ字表を引くと
あの 何て言いますか しらさぎ
しらさぎ しらさぎと言うんですか？あの鳥
鳥